let's solve some aromaticity problems we
have a two-part question here
we need to classify the compounds as
aromatic non aromatic or anti aromatic
and draw the lone pairs on hetero atoms
and determine if they participate in the
PI system or are orthogonal to it a
hetero atom is a non carbon atom and
orthogonal means the lone pair is
perpendicular to the PI system this is
important because it cannot participate
in the PI system when orthogonal may be
pause the video here and try to classify
these compounds on your own when you
resume we can solve the problems
together as a refresher let's review the
criteria for aromaticity the compound
must be cyclic and planar in our
examples we have relatively small rings
containing double bonds so planarity is
probably not a major concern and our
problems but it can be with larger rings
the compound must also be conjugated the
continuous PI system within the ring can
be made up of sp2 hybridized atoms and
lone pairs finally the number of
electrons in the PI system must satisfy
huckel's rule having 4n plus 2 pi
electrons all abbreviate electrons II -
now if we replace n with zero or small
positive integers we find that our PI
system must have a specific number of
electrons to be aromatic we may also
need to identify anti aromatic compounds
which are cyclic planar compounds that
have a continuous PI system containing 4
n PI electrons anti aromatic compounds
are very unstable in problem a we have
alternating single and double bonds and
we can see this pattern continues across
two rings we can draw a resonance form
to show electron delocalization over the
bi-cyclic compound remember each of our
representations is an average of the
actual structure although it looks like
this bond is moved here and this bond
has moved to the other ring let's count
PI electrons
each double bond is made up of two
electrons so we have two four six eight
pi electrons in this system which makes
it anti aromatic moving from a
hydrocarbon example to a heterocycle
with nitrogen atoms in the ring we have
a bit of a different situation each
nitrogen has a lone pair so we need to
figure out whether or not they can
participate in the PI system it's
helpful to look at a model for this one
we can see the blue double bonds and
green single bonds which is a reasonable
representation for the PI system in this
static model even though in reality
delocalization makes each bond more like
a one and a half bond notice the
geometry at nitrogen since it is sp2
hybridized the lone pair must fit into
this hole which sticks out at a 120
degree angle to the other bonds the PI
system is delocalized above and below
the ring so the lone pairs on an sp2
hybridized nitrogen are orthogonal to
the aromatic PI system so this compound
called pyridine has three double bonds
in the ring making the compound aromatic
and it also has two orthogonal lone
pairs problem C has a positively charged
nitrogen it has shared its lone pair to
bond with oxygen forming an n oxide
functional group it has four bonds which
gives it tetrahedral geometry and makes
it sp3 hybridized the sp3 nitrogen atom
disrupts conjugation in the ring and
this compound is non aromatic problem D
is an interesting example each oxygen
has two lone pairs so each atom in the
ring has either a lone pair or is sp2
hybridized
however this compound is non aromatic as
drawn let's examine why
we can show a resonance form by pushing
electrons through the entire conjugated
system putting a negative charge on the
oxygen outside of the ring and using one
of the lone pairs of the ring oxygen we
had to push electrons in a path that led
outside of the Ring to show this
resonance form thus the conjugated
system is not continuous within the ring
so the compound on the left is non
aromatic now the form on the right does
indeed have aromatic character but
because of the charge separation it
contributes less to the overall
structure also our problem asked if the
compound was aromatic as drawn there is
a second way to push electrons in this
system but it also relies on conjugation
with the exocyclic double bond in
compound e we again have an sp2 nitrogen
with an orthogonal lone pair if we look
at the model of this compound it is so
strained that the double bonds are
bending but it certainly is planar since
two double bonds make up the PI system
this is an anti aromatic compound this
compound with a positively charged
sulfur atom has three double bonds
within the ring so what about the lone
pairs on sulfur sulfur is in the same
group as oxygen on the periodic table so
only considering the valence SP hybrid
orbital we can draw a lone pair on
sulfur that does not participate in the
PI system so this compound has six PI
electrons and is aromatic in our final
example we should recognize immediately
that the nitrogen lone pairs are
orthogonal to the PI system we can draw
two lone pairs on sulfur one of which
participates in the PI system
geometrically the second lone pair
cannot participate so it is outside of
the PI system they'll maybe not exactly
perpendicular to it given the two double
bonds in the ring and the lone pair on
sulfur compound G is aromatic